uh look i don't know where the signs of
hope are here but i think raheem morris
may be coaching his way into the job the
problem is it's not going to be easy the
rest of the way they still got the bucks
twice the saints twice they got the
chiefs coming up
uh it's not going to be easy yeah got
the raiders they've certainly had a
better look about their football team i
mean
i don't think there's any doubt about
that offense is better defense is better
defense has been like a lot better
uh i i mean i think that's the thing
that's jumped out to me more than
anything
and then raheem seems to have the guys
believing and playing
playing hard i mean they're physical
he's brought a little creativity to the
defensive side of the ball and the
things they do there
and of course we know they got weapons
on the offensive side of the ball i
don't know
i don't know if he can realistically
save his own job and become the head
coach i'll be interested to see where
this goes
i mean they're an interesting team all
together and just that that all
but but uh they look better i'll say
that but i still don't expect them to
make the playoffs i don't i don't i
think the schedule is too tough down the
down the road here and they'll lose you
know another game or two
for sure yeah i look i i agree with you
completely this is about deciding
whether or not raheem is the guy
and this is going to be the challenge
if you're arthur blank the owner of the
team rich mckay the ceo look they're
going to hire a gm
also but will they do enough
in games that they are likely to lose if
they do indeed lose those games
to still convince the powers that be
that raheem morris
is the answer are they going to feel
compelled to just rip the band-aid off
that would be we need somebody who
wasn't connected to any of that stuff
that's going on here that's the question
yeah that that to me i i think that's
the big question do you really want to
continue this you know prior
regime really or do you want to rip it
off and let's just get all new ideas new
new everything new coaches of course the
new gm
and just an overall re-haul of the
organizational belief
that is what they're going to have to
real you know figure out here down the
stretch
raheem's awesome i got a lot of
experience with raheem he's got great
energy he's a great leader he's an
outside the box thinker he deserves to
be a head coach again
he does i just don't know if that right
now with atlanta is the right time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports